a un camino de nieve en medio de las
montañas por primera vez en la historia
de los juegos olímpicos de invierno los
juegos se organizan solo con nieve
artificial
durante varias semanas los cañones han
estado rociando sitios con más de 2
millones de metros cúbicos de agua y
aunque los atletas son conscientes del
daño ambiental no hay nada que puedan
hacer
hubiera preferido una ubicación con
nieve natural y creo que deberíamos
estar de acuerdo en decirlo para que los
eventos futuros tengan en cuenta el
impacto ambiental no es algo que me vaya
a impedir disfrutar de estos juegos
porque en cualquier caso el daño está
hecho estamos todos aquí todos juntos de
perú son las autoridades chinas han
estado vendiendo hasta ahora unos juegos
de invierno respetuosos con el medio
ambiente llenos de autobuses de
hidrógeno turbinas eólicas paneles
solares y con 100 por ciento de
electricidad proveniente de energías
renovables pero los juegos ya han tenido
un impacto ambiental con una parte de
una pista de nieve construida en una
reserva natural
estos son los juegos que conozco ya sea
pensando o sochi los sitios se
construyeron el evento es todo lo que se
mueve en los últimos juegos olímpicos de
invierno el 90% de la nieve utilizada
era falsa y aunque esta vez todo es
artificial la mayoría de los atletas
dicen que las condiciones son buenas